l'horrible à gros monstre caché derrière
le manche du ballet ah mais non ce n'est
pas possible par un gros monstre ne peut
pas se cacher derrière un manche à balai
non pour un pour cacher un monstre il
faut au moins une armoire
ah ben oui mais entre une armoire et le
mur
il n'y a pas beaucoup de place or là
comment faire ah mais ça y est j'ai
trouvé voilà c'est ça leur guise le gros
monstre caché derrière l'armoire qui se
trouve au milieu du salon très très bien
en temps arrivé le chevalier blanc qui
le bond est noble chevalier blanc très
bien ils tremblent de peur
le chevalier arrive à et ses cris ou de
castes eu gredins horrible gros monstre
vient que je te coupe les ongles du pied
gauche à pied gauche mon propre voire
abominables et féroce dragon épouvantail
à moineaux poltron
las mon trottoir que je te laves des
oreilles 3 mai sera très bien tout ça
tu entendu ça oui je ne comprends pas il
a l'air dans une colère terrible et je
ne vois personne d'autre
c'est ça qui m'inquiète il se passe
quelque chose d'anormal à ce moment là
leur noble et beau chevalier blanc
découvre l'horrible gros monstre
derrière l'armoire
celui-ci tremble de peur et s'écrit
pitié pitié
oui je vous en supplie ne me fait pas
mal beau et noble chevalier blanc
je ne suis qu'un horrible gros monstre
pitié je demande s'il n'est pas son nom
gül
tu sais qu'il ya des gens qui parlent et
qui marchent en dormant oui oui tu crois
qui fait un cauchemar c'est pas bête ça
je crois qu'il doit avoir raison alors
allons-y attention françois
il paraît que c'est très dangereux de
réveiller un semblant mais non je n'ai
aucune pitié pour toi l'instant est venu
de payer des climats tu as enlevé la
douce et jolie princesse que je dois
épouser être qu'est ce que vous faites
là j'étais malade
attention casimir il faut surtout pas te
réveiller ça pourrait être dangereux
et pourquoi ce qu'il ne faut pas me
réveiller gens ne barre pas mais c'est
vrai que tu dors pas puisque tu nous
parles par du verre à l'air a peur du
ridicule non pas un peu complètement
ridicule dès lors casimir et qu'est ce
que tu faisais en train de parler tout
seul comme ça j'écris une pièce de
théâtre
j'ai fait un choix qui va être joué
ouais à des acteurs va bien sûr par des
kangoo et qui seront les acteurs les
meilleurs de nos enfants j'espère que
cette vie n'est je vois peu aussi il
s'agit de monsieur du snav et deux mois
oyo repas qui roule pour moi n'a pour
moi non plus non non un tout petit rôle
même pas de la figuration rien du tout
il s'agit d'une pièce à deux personnages
hamid bonjour monsieur les choses sur
les images j'ai reçu ton petit mot vous
demandant de venir tout de suite avec
vous n'êtes même pas venu en courant
mon pauvre casimir je ne peux pas
recourir je resterai de poids c'est mon
costume en toile de californie était ce
si urgent que ça non pas vraiment mais
ça m'aurait fait plaisir
casimir ci lui expliquer à monsieur du
snob pourquoi tu lui as demandé de venir
vous allez va c'est formidable c'est
vous qui le dites très cher ami
[Musique]
alors de quoi s'agit-il
et bien voila voila voila quoi par me
coûter si vous interrompez et bien je
n'arriverai pas à vous expliquer que
j'ai écrit une pièce de théâtre c'est
que je voudrais que vous la jouer avec
moi une pièce de théâtre
à deux personnages beaucoup d'action
mais c'est d'intérêt grandiose et quels
sont les deux personnages et bien il y a
le nombre est beau chevalier blanc l
horrible gros mots arts vient très très
bien mais je ne sais pas encore quel
personnage vous allez jouer à pau
whissell sait pas qui va jouer
l'horrible gros moments très difficiles
il faut que les acteurs à ressemble bien
leur personnage et hu devraient nous
raconter l'histoire et oui ça nous
permettrait de vous aider
et bien voilà
c'est l'histoire du noble et bosso
vanier blanc qui recherchent l'horrible
gros monstres pour la tuer
et d'après ce que j'ai cru comprendre le
noble chevalier blanc est très courageux
ils gros monstres et tremblante heures
ils demandent si tu y es alors quel rôle
voulez vous jouer et bien aussi c'était
possiblement le personnage qui
m'intéresserait le plus serait celui du
noble et beau chevalier blanc
c'est dommage je vous aurais plutôt vu
dans le rôle du monde
mais enfin si vous insistez j'aurais
moi-même
ce sera un rôle de composition
[Musique]
j'ai eu beaucoup de mal à me déguiser en
horrible gros monstre mais je crois que
c'est assez réussi
ne suis-je pas super mais chevalier
blanc
vous êtes très bien vous êtes parfait
vous êtes superbe tous les deux bon
allez on va commencer à temps kazimi tu
n'as pas donné la fin du texte
j'aurais que dire juste quelques gifles
et c'est tout amadou bah comme michelin
ou rip ne le batte et pas trop fun vous
le promets chers amis jeunes comiques
venez pognon comme un fils j'ai très
peur je suis l'horrible gros monstre et
je suis poursuivi par le beau et noble
chevalier blanc
où vais-je me cacher à une armoire
casson nous ou de casutt eu d'horribles
gros montre bien que je te coupe les
ongles de pied gauche nous montre toi
féroce c'est terrible dragon ou 3 0
c'est terrible dragon slash poltron
épouvantail à moineaux que je te laves
les aurel bo1
ayez pitié ne me fait pas mal beau et
noble chevalier blanc ne sont qu'un
pauvre dragon non je n'ai pas de pitié
tu dois payer tes crimes l'heure est
venue tu vas vous lui enlevez là tout
est jolie princesse que je dois être
prouvé d'abord elle n'est pas seule il
quoi elle n'est pas joli et puis j'avais
assez de vous beau et noble chevalier
installé sa trempe et sa equis à part çà
et là
la pièce que nous venons de jouer devant
vous ce soir pour la première fois
s'appelle l'horrible gros monstre prat
concorde le test et de casimir
bravo la mise en scène de casimir et le
rôle du gros monstre joué par casimir
[Applaudissements]